[Musique]
non ce n'était pas le radeau de la
méduse ce bateau qu'on se le dise au
fond des ports 10 au fond l'époque
il n'avait y est en père peinard sur la
grand mare des canards et s'appeler les
copains d'abord les copains d'abord
c'est fluctuat nec mergitur c'était pas
la littérature
n'en déplaise aux acheteurs le sort aux
jouteurs le sort
son capitaine et ses matelots n'étaient
pas des enfants salon
mais les amis franco de port des copains
d'abord
c'était pas des amis le luxe d petit
castor et pollux des gens de sodome et
gomorrhe sodome et gomorrhe
c'était pas des amis choisis par
montaigne et la poésie sur le vendre il
se tapait fort les copains d'abord
c'était pas des anges non plus
l'évangile il n'avait pas lu mais il
sait mais toutes voiles dehors on te
voit leur
plan pierre paul et compagnie c'était
leur seule licka ni leur credo leur
confie t on aux copains d'abord
au moindre coup de trafalgar assez
l'amitié qui prenait car c'est elle qui
leur montrer le nord leur montrer le
chemin
et quand il était en détresse leur
balancer des sincères on aurait dit des
sémaphores les copains d'abord
au rendez vous et bon cop n y avait pas
souvent de la peine quand l'un d'entre
eux manquait d'abord c'est qu'il était
mort
oui mais jamais au grand jamais son taux
dans l'autre se refermer sans quand
après qu'aucun le saut il manquait
encore
des bateaux j'en ai pris beaucoup mais
le seul qui est nul qui n'est jamais
virer de bord mais virer le bol
navigue est en père peinard sur la grand
mare des canards et s'appeler les
copains d'abord les copains d'abord
[Musique]